SOMEDAY, SERIOUS.
>> Sean: OKAY, DONE.
THANKS, TUCKER, GREAT SHOW,
WELCOME TO HANNITY.
BREAKING TONIGHT, HE'LL JOHN
SOLOMON WE HAVE MAJOR EVIDENCE
OF ELECTION COLLUSION IN 2016,
REAL EVIDENCE TO BACK IT UP,
THIS COLLUSION WITH
HILLARY CLINTON AND TOP
UKRAINIAN GOVERNMENT OFFICIAL
THAT WANTED HER ELECTED.
WE WILL HAVE ALL THE DETAILS
COMING UP WITH JOHN SOLOMON.
BUT BEFORE WE GET TO THE TOP
STORY ASK YOURSELF A COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS, WILL THIS BE
INVESTIGATED FOR THREE YEARS,
TWO BY EULER AND ONE BY THE FBI
AND BANNED THE DEMOCRATIC
DONORS?
WILL THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA CAN
EVEN COVER A STORY WITH TAPES?
WE WILL NOT HOLD OUR BREATH,
THAT STORY AND MUCH MORE
TONIGHT.
WE FIRST TURN OUR ATTENTION TO
HANNITY WATCH, THE CROP OF
DEMOCRATIC HOPEFULS.
DEMOCRATS PUSHING TO GIVE
16-YEAR-OLDS THE RIGHT TO VOTE,
AGAINST DRINK TO YOU CAN'T DRINK
TILL 21 TO STACK THE
SUPREME COURT SO THEY GET ENOUGH
JUSTICES THAT THINK THEIR WAY
AND WILL LEGISLATE FROM THE
BENCH AND PROPOSING AN END TO
THE ELECTORAL COLLEGE.
NOW WHAT IS HAPPENING, WE WILL
BREAK IT DOWN.
THIS IS A SCARY ATTEMPT BY
POLITICIANS TO CENTRALIZE POWER
AND CONTROL THE LIVES OF YOU,
WE, THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
AND RIGHT NOW, IT IS THE PARTY
LINE AMONG ALMOST ALL THE
RADICAL DEMOCRATS RUNNING TO BE
PRESIDENT IN 2020.
A BLATANT, DRAMATIC FRIGHTENING
ATTEMPT TO ALTER AMERICA IN WAYS
THAT WILL MAKE IT UNRECOGNIZABLE
FOR EVER DESTROYED THAT GREATEST
ECONOMIC CREATION SYSTEM IN THE
HISTORY OF MANKIND.
NOW, LAST NIGHT DURING THE
FRIENDLY INTERVIEW, SO-CALLED
COMEDIAN JIMMY KIMMEL, OUR OLD
FRIEND, SENATOR KAMALA HARRIS
BECAME THE LATEST DEMOCRATIC
CANDIDATE TO EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR
AN END TO THE ELECTORAL COLLEGE.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> SENATOR WARREN, ELIZABETH
WARREN HAD A TOWN HALL LAST
NIGHT AND SHE SAID SHE THINKS WE
SHOULD DO IT AWAY WITH ELECTORAL
COLLEGES.
DO YOU AGREE WITH THAT?
>> I THINK THAT IT IS OPEN TO
DISCUSSION.
I MEAN, THERE IS NO QUESTION
THAT THE POPULAR VOTE HAS BEEN
DIMINISHED IN TERMS OF MAKING
THE FINAL DECISION ABOUT WHO THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
AND WE NEED TO DEAL WITH THAT.
SO I'M OPEN TO THE DISCUSSION.
>> Sean: SENATOR HARRIS,
ELIZABETH WARREN, KRISTEN
GILLIBRAND AND MANY DEMOCRATS
SUPPORTED AND TO THE
CONSTITUTIONAL PROCESS BY WHICH
WE HAVE ALWAYS ELECTED THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
SO WHY IS THIS A BIG DEAL?
WE TURNED QUICKLY TO HANNITY
HISTORY LESSON ON THE ELECTORAL
COLLEGE TO GIVE YOU AN OPEN
EXPLANATION.
WHEN OUR CONSTITUTION WAS
DRAFTED IN 1787, THE FRAMERS OF
THE CONSTITUTION, THEY SOUGHT TO
RECTIFY WHAT WAS A VERY
CHALLENGING CONUNDRUM.
HOW DO YOU CREATE A LIMITED,
CENTRAL GOVERNMENT STRONG ENOUGH
TO DEFEND ITS PEOPLE AGAINST
SERIOUS THREATS BUT
DECENTRALIZED ENOUGH TO PREVENT
CONSOLIDATION AND SUBSTANCE
ABUSE OF POWER?
THE RESULT WAS A CONSTITUTION
FILLED WITH CHECKS, BALANCES,
SHARED POWER BETWEEN THE
INDIVIDUAL STATES AND THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
THE ELECTORAL COLLEGE IS A
PRODUCT OF THIS SYSTEM GIVING
THE STATES THE POWER TO CONDUCT
ELECTIONS AND CHOOSE THE
PRESIDENT.
AS A RESULT, EACH STATE HOLDS
SOME POWER IN DETERMINING THE
EXECUTIVE BRANCH.
LET ME EXPLAIN.
WITHOUT THE ELECTORAL COLLEGE
AND THE FRAMERS KNEW THIS,
SMALLER AREAS WITH DENSE
POPULATIONS COME IN OTHER WORDS,
NEW YORK, NEW JERSEY,
CALIFORNIA, WOULD MONOPOLIZE THE
KEYS TO THE WHITE HOUSE.
AND LOOK AT HOW ALL FOUR OF
THOSE STATES HAVE BEEN DESTROYED
BY THE PEOPLE IN THOSE STATES
THAT ELECTED LIBERAL SOCIALIST
POLITICIANS.
EVERYWHERE ELSE COME IN OTHER
WORDS, ALL OF RED AMERICA PRETTY
MUCH TOTALLY WOULD BE IGNORED.
DON'T TAKE IT FROM ME.
LISTEN TO WHAT OBAMA'S FORMER
CAMPAIGN MANAGER HAD TO SAY
ABOUT THIS.
TAKE A LISTEN.
THE CAMPAIGN MANAGER STANDPOINT
WHEN I RAN PRESIDENT OBAMA'S
CAMPAIGN WE WOULD NEVER GO TO A
SMALL STATE IF THERE WAS NO
ELECTORAL COLLEGE.
YOU WILL GO TO THE MAJOR
MARKETS, YOU WOULD NOT GO TO
IOWA, MONTANA, NEW HAMPSHIRE.
I THINK ANY PROPOSAL GETTING RID
OF THE ELECTORAL COLLEGE.
I UNDERSTAND THE CONCERN AND THE
CONCERN IS REAL THAT WE'VE HAD
TWO COPRESIDENTS GET ELECTED
WITHOUT WINNING A POPULAR VOTE,
BUT I AGREE WITH CHARLIE.
THAT IS NOT GOING TO HAPPEN.
>> Sean: IN OTHER WORDS POWER
WOULD BE TOTALLY CONSOLIDATED.
THIS SCENARIO, THE FRAMERS, THE
FOUNDERS HERE ARE THE MOST.
ONE OF THE REASONS THE COURT OF
THOMAS JEFFERSON, HE HATED
CITIES WRITING THEY ARE HARMFUL
TO THE MORALS, THE HEALTH AND
LIBERTY OF MAN.
HE WAS SMART, WAY AHEAD OF HIS
TIME.
AND FOR HUNDREDS OF YEARS, THE
ELECTORAL COLLEGE PLAYED IN A
RURAL WORLD DECENTRALIZING POWER
AT THE CENTRAL GOVERNMENT
KEEPING THE UNITED STATES
UNITED.
IN THOSE RED STATES TO STICK
AROUND AND BE IN THE
UNITED STATES IF THEY KEPT
LOSING TO NEW YORK, NEW JERSEY,
CALIFORNIA AND ILLINOIS?
I TEND TO THINK NOT.
DEMOCRATS DON'T SHARE THE VALUES
OF OUR FRAMERS.
THEY WANT POWER FOR THEMSELVES,
AND THEY WANTED AT ALL COST.
THAT IS WHY EVERY MAJOR PROPOSAL
IS NOW PUSHING BEGINS AND ENDS
WITH THEIR POWER AND A
CENTRALIZED FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
THAT THEY CONTROL.
GOVERNMENT RUN HEALTH CARE AND
COMPLETE TAKEOVER OF THE
HEALTH CARE INDUSTRY, YES, RUN
BY THE STATE.
KAMALA HARRIS AND OTHERS, THEY
WANT TO END ALL PRIVATE
HEALTH CARE.
THAT IMPACTS 200 MILLION
AMERICANS.
I THOUGHT THEY WERE PRO-CHOICE.
GOVERNMENT RUN EDUCATION.
NOW THEY HAVE TO ADD PRE-K AND
COLLEGE EDUCATION.
THEY HAVEN'T DONE A BETTER
ENOUGH JOB WITH KINDERGARTEN
THROUGH 12TH GRADE.
AND THEY WILL HAVE GOVERNMENT
CONSOLIDATION OF ALL GUNS AND
GUN LAWS.
GOVERNMENT RUN CLEAN ENERGY
THROUGH THE GOVERNMENT TAKEOVER
OF THE ENERGY SECTOR.
IN OTHER WORDS, THEY WILL TAKE
IT OVER.
NO MORE WILLING CAST PROPOSAL
FOR TEN YEARS OR WE WILL DIE.
GOVERNMENT RUN IN -- UNIVERSAL
GOVERNMENT PAID RETIREMENT,
GOVERNMENT PAID FOR VACATION,
GOVERNMENT-SPONSORED HEALTHY
FOOD.
THE 2020 CANDIDATES EVEN WANT
GOVERNMENT TO CONTROL MEANS OF
PRODUCTION.
IN OTHER WORDS, THE SOCIALIST
GREEN NEW DEAL, THEY PROPOSED
AND WILL TELL YOU HOW TO RUN
YOUR BUSINESS.
GOVERNMENT PROMISES FOR
EVERYTHING AND FOR EVERYBODY, HE
WILL NEVER HAVE A WORRY IN THE
WORLD, BUT YOU ALSO GIVE UP ALL
OF YOUR FREEDOM.
AND ALL OF THE WEALTH CREATION
SYSTEMS WE HAVE BUILT UP TO THIS
POINT IN OUR HISTORY.
WE WILL EXPLAIN.
EVEN THE POOREST IN AMERICA HAVE
IT SO MUCH BETTER THAN SO MANY
OTHER PEOPLE AROUND THE GLOBE.
THE MANY MODELING DETAILING THIS
DESTRUCTION.
WHAT DO SOCIAL MEAN QUESTION
LATER IN THE PROGRAM, SOMETHINGN
LATER IN THE PROGRAM, SOMETHINGO
DEMOCRAT SEEMS CAPABLE OF AND
WE WILL ACTUALLY DO THE MATH AND
TELL YOU HOW MUCH YOUR
PAYCHECK THE DEMOCRATS WANT TO
TAKE.
IT IS PRETTY CLOSE TO 100%.
IF THE DEMOCRATS GET THEIR WAY,
THIS COUNTRY AS WE KNOW IT, IT
IS GOING TO BE OVER.
IT IS DONE.
IT WILL NOT BE THE UNITED STATES
WITH AMERICA AS WE KNOW IT.
WE TURNED THE HANNITY WATCH ON
THE WITCH HUNT AND GET TO A
BREAKING NEWS.
ANOTHER SIGN THAT THE PROBE IS
IN ITS FINAL STATE, SPECIAL
COUNSEL PATERNITY'S AN EXTENSION
FOR A COURT FILING RELATING TO
THE METAPHORIC CASE BECAUSE THEY
WERE TOO BUSY WITH THE PRESS --
WRITING REPORTS AFTER NEARLY
THREE YEARS AND TODAY,
PRESIDENT TRUMP SAYS HE WANTS
THE REPORT TO BE AVAILABLE FOR
ALL AMERICANS, TAKE A LISTEN.
>> LET IT COME OUT.
LET PEOPLE SEE IT, LEAVE IT UP
TO THE ATTORNEY GENERAL.
WE HAVE A VERY GOOD ATTORNEY
GENERAL, HIGHLY RESPECTED MAN.
WE WILL SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
I WANT TO SEE THE REPORT.
AND YOU WILL WANT TO SEE IT.
TENS OF MILLIONS OF PEOPLE THAT
LOVE THE FACT THAT WE HAVE THE
GREATEST ECONOMY WE HAVE EVER
HAD.
I KNOW NOTHING ABOUT IT.
I KNOW HE IS CONFLICTED.
AND I KNOW HIS BEST FRIEND IS
COMEY WHO IS A BAD COP.
AND I KNOW THERE ARE OTHER
THINGS, OBVIOUSLY, YOU KNOW I
HAD A BUSINESS TRANSACTION WITH
HIM.
THAT I HAVE REPORTED MANY TIMES.
THAT YOU PEOPLE DON'T TALK
ABOUT.
I HAD A NASTY BUSINESS
TRANSACTION WITH HIM AND OTHER
THINGS.
I KNOW HE PUT 13 HIGHLY
CONFLICTED AND VERY ANGRY, I
CALLED HIM ANGRY DEMOCRATS END.
WITH ALL OF THAT SAID TO COME I
LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING THE
REPORT.
>> Sean: HERE IS THE IRONIC,
THE IMPEACHMENT OF BILL CLINTON,
THE PRESIDENT HAS NO SAY
WHATSOEVER IN THAT DECISION
WHETHER TO MAKE THE FINDINGS
PUBLIC.
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL AND ONLY
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL WILL
DECIDE.
TONIGHT AS WE WAIT THE MUELLER
REPORT, AND WANT TO GET BACK TO
HOW THIS BEGAN.
THIS IS IMPORTANT FOR THOSE
PEOPLE TO ABSORB EXACTLY WHAT
THIS IS ALL PREDICATED ON.
ACCORDING TO THEN LEAD FBI
INVESTIGATOR PETER STRZOK AND
TOP LAWYER LISA PAGE COME AFTER
NINE MONTHS OF AN FBI
INVESTIGATION BEGINNING IN JULY
OF 2016, THEY FOUND NO EVIDENCE
OF TRUMP RUSSIA COLLUSION.
NINE MONTHS BEFORE MUELLER.
SO AFTER THE PRESIDENT RIGHTLY
FIRED COMEY WHICH COMEY SAID THE
PRESIDENT HAS THE RIGHT TO DO
FOR ANY REASON OR NO REASON AT
ALL, THEN THE DEPUTY A.J. ROB
ROSENSTEIN, HE APPOINTED SPECIAL
COUNSEL, HIS FRIEND ROBERT
MUELLER TO CONTINUE THE FBI
INVESTIGATION INTO SO-CALLED
COLLUSION.
REMEMBER JEFF SESSIONS RECUSED
HIMSELF.
NOW MUELLER'S MANDATE WAS AS
FOLLOWS, INVESTIGATE "ANY LINKS
AND OR COORDINATION BETWEEN THE
RUSSIAN GOVERNMENT AND
INDIVIDUALS ASSOCIATED WITH THE
CAMPAIGN OF
PRESIDENT DONALD TRUMP.
AND THIS PART THAT EVERYONE
SEEMS TO FORGET.
ANY MATTERS THAT AROSE OR MAY
ARISE DIRECTLY FROM THE
INVESTIGATION.
NOW WE HAVE SEEN ROBERT MUELLER
PROSECUTE VARIOUS TRUMPET
ASSOCIATIONS FOR CRIMES.
PAUL MANAFORT FOR CRIMES THEY
HAD NOTHING TO DO WITH HIS TIE
WITH TROMP, RUSSIA COLLUSION ANY
WORK FOR THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
WE WATCH MUELLER A TROLL FARM
FILLED WITH PEOPLE WHO WILL
NEVER BE EXTRADITED AND TRIED IN
THE UNITED STATES TO FACE
JUSTICE.
AND RUSSIA INTEL PEOPLE.
THEY WILL NEVER BE TRIED.
THEY WILL NEVER BE EXTRADITED.
BUT ODDLY ENOUGH, WE HAVE NOT
SEEN MUELLER PROSECUTE MATTERS
THAT AROSE FROM OR INVOLVING
DEMOCRATS OR OBAMA ALLIES.
AND THE MUELLER INVESTIGATION
INTO WHETHER THE CLINTON
CAMPAIGN USED MONEY AND USED AND
FUNNELED THAT MONEY TO A SPY,
CHRISTOPHER STEELE WHO HATED
DONALD TRUMP WHO THEN COLLUDED
WITH RUSSIA IN A DEVELOPMENT OF
THE DIRTY DOSSIER.
WE KNOW THAT DOSSIER IS FILLED
WITH RUSSIAN LIONESS AND
UKRAINIAN LIES AND TOTAL
PROPAGANDA.
WHERE IS THE MUELLER INTO PFIZER
ABUSE?
AFTER ALL CLEAR AND EVIDENCE
THAT TRUMP CAMPAIGN ASSOCIATE
SPIED ON BY OFFICIALS, THE BULK
OF THE INFORMATION AND THE FISA
APPLICATION THAT HILLARY PAID
FOR THE DOSSIER.
THEY NEVER TOLD THE COURT THAT
HILARY PAID FOR IT.
WHERE IS THE MUELLER
INVESTIGATION INTO THE
COORDINATION AND THE EFFORT OF
THE STATE DEPARTMENT TO USE THE
CLINTON BOUGHT AND PAID FOR
RUSSIAN DOSSIER TO TAKE DOWN
DONALD TRUMP WHO WISH THEY --
WHO THEY WISH DID NOT WIN THE
CAMPAIGN.
RUSSIA ACTUALLY HAD AN FBI AGENT
AND THEY ARE AND THAT WAS
REPORTING BACK BRIBERY KICKBACKS
MONDAY LAUNDERING AND
RACKETEERING.
WE KNOW BILL CLINTON AT THE TIME
TOOK A MASSIVE PAYMENT FROM A
RUSSIAN BANK WITH URANIAN ONE
AND MET WITH VLADIMIR PUTIN AND
RUSSIA.
WE KNOW THE CLINTON FOUNDATION
RAKED IN ABOUT $145 MILLION FROM
URANIAN ONE EXECUTIVES.
WE KNOW HILLARY CLINTON AS
SECRETARY OF STATE, WELL, ONE OF
A NUMBER OF PEOPLE SIGNING OFF
ON THAT DEAL.
URANIAN ONE DEAL, THAT IS RIGHT,
GIVING 20% OF AMERICA'S URANIAN
FROM -- TO RUSSIA AND
VLADIMIR PUTIN FOUNDATIONAL
MATERIAL FOR NUCLEAR WEAPONS
THAT WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH ON OUR
OWN BUT WE IMPORT URANIUM.
WHERE IS THE MUELLER
INVESTIGATION INTO THIS NEWS
STORY WHICH WE GET TO TONIGHT
FROM JOHN SOLOMON?
WE KNOW THAT A HIGH RANKING
GOVERNMENT OFFICIAL IN UKRAINE
ACTIVELY TRIED TO BENEFIT, THE
CLINTON CAMPAIGN IN 2016.
THIS IS BREAKING TONIGHT
ACCORDING TO SOLOMON, UKRAINE'S
TOP PROSECUTOR HAS OPENED A
CRIMINAL PROBE INTO WHETHER
SENIOR LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICIALS
IN THAT COUNTRY TRIED TO SWAY
THE U.S. ELECTION, INFLUENCE OUR
ELECTION TO HELP HILLARY CLINTON
WIN.
NOW A TAPE RECORDING RELEASED BY
A MEMBER OF UKRAINIAN PARLIAMENT
CAPTURED IN AN OFFICIAL TALKING
ABOUT LEAKING, FINANCIAL RECORDS
OF THE 2016 ELECTION FOR THE
STATED PURPOSE TO HELP
HILLARY CLINTON.
THOUGH YOU REALLY -- THE
EUREKA -- TO INFLUENCE THE
AMERICAN ELECTION AND THAT'S NOT
ALL ACCORDING TO THE REPORT BY
JOHN SOLOMON, UKRAINE'S TOP
PROSECUTOR ACCUSED THE
U.S. EMBASSY OF INTERFERING IN
CORRUPTION PROSECUTION INSIDE TE
CORRUPTION PROSECUTION INSIDE TC
CORRUPTION PROSECUTION INSIDE TU
CORRUPTION PROSECUTION INSIDE TT
CORRUPTION PROSECUTION INSIDE TY
INCLUDING ONE PROBE INTO
THE ALLEGED MISUSE OF AMERICAN A
THE ALLEGED MISUSE OF AMERICAN D
THE ALLEGED MISUSE OF AMERICAN E
THE ALLEGED MISUSE OF AMERICAN T
THE ALLEGED MISUSE OF AMERICAN R
THE ALLEGED MISUSE OF AMERICAN S
THE ALLEGED MISUSE OF AMERICAN A
THE ALLEGED MISUSE OF AMERICAN E
FROM SENIOR MEMBER OF
SECRETARY POMPEO WITH THE U.S.
AMBASSADOR OF BAD MOUTHING TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION.
THIS IS EXACTLY WHAT MARK
MEADOWS WAS TALKING ABOUT
TUESDAY ON THEIR SHOW.
SO WHERE IS THE MUELLER
INVESTIGATION INTO THESE
MATTERS?
AFTER ALL, IT IS ALREADY UNDER
INVESTIGATION AND THE COUNTRY
UKRAINE.
THERE IS A TAPE RECORDING THAT
HAS ALL OF THIS INFORMATION.
WHERE IS EQUAL JUSTICE UNDER OUR
LAWS?
WHERE'S APPLICATION OF THE LAWS?
NOTE TRUMP COLLUSION AS WE NOW
KNOW FROM THE FBI TOLD US AFTER
NINE MONTHS AND OF COURSE, THE
COMMITTEE TOLD US AND THE SENATE
INTEL COMMITTEE TOLD US AND
CONGRESSMAN NUNEZ TOLD US MANY
YEARS AGO, BY THE WAY, 2014.
RUSSIAN INTERFERENCE, HE TOLD US
IS A REAL THREAT.
HE WANT US IN 2014.
AND NOT TO THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN,
INSTEAD, BY THE WAY, THE POWER
OF CLINTON WHO MADE MOST
ACCEPTABLE.
THE REAL COLLUSION.